chez l'homme
enzo enzo mais tu ne peux pas savoir le
plaisir que tu nous fait de venir leur
rendre visite dans renversant on t'adore
moi je t'adore vraiment et justement ça
tombe bien parce que pour cet épisode de
renversant on avait un peu envie de se
retrouver au calme loin de l'actualité
anxiogène et c'est justement le fil
rouge de ton album s'appelle au calme au
calme quand j'ai enregistré l'album
j'étais
plutôt
dans la tempête il se trouve que j'ai
rassemblé depuis quelques
danem des chansons qui me réjouit ce qui
me nourrit ce qui me donne envie de les
emmener sur scène parce qu'elle
elle m'apporte des images poétiques ce
qu'elle m'apporte une réflexion parce
qu'elle m'apporte un réconfort parce
qu'elle aborde des sujets de de
confiance en l'avenir en ce que l'homme
et en ce que nous sommes en ce qui nous
attend elle parle de de bien-être
vraiment possible en cas lyon lequel il
faut croire et quand l'album a été
enregistré
il a fallu lui donner un nom et cette
paire laquelle j'ai inspiré tous ces
derniers temps
elle s'entendait dans l'album qu'on a
enregistrées dans la manière dont on l'a
enregistré dans le choix des chansons et
donc le titre au calme correspond à
quelque chose dont j'avais besoin ou
dont j'avais envie et qui ressemble au
son de l'album dans cet album il ya
aussi beaucoup en filigrane la question
du temps qui passe notamment dans une
des chansons qui s'appelle ballet de
crin il ya cette phrase alors je vais
essayer de la cité de mémoire
j'ai répété 60 fois l'enfance autant
d'été qu'est ce qu'elle me dit tu de ton
rapport au temps cette phrase ça veut
dire que j'ai pas peur d'en parler
déjà te dire que j'ai fait soixante fois
la visite de mon enfance ce que ce que
j'aime bien dans le temps qui passe et
qu'on se connaît mieux
moi pour être honnête je je dirais que
je connais plus la joie et le plaisir
en vieillissant
j'aimerais qu'on parle aussi de la
chanson juste quelqu'un de bien parce
que ça a été un jalon dans ta vie mais
ça a été un jalon dans nos vies à tous
et pourtant c'est assez étonnant parce
que grâce à cette chanson tu es une
victoire de la musique alors pour plein
d'artistes avoir une victoire deux
victoires de la musique pardon pour
plein d'artistes ça valide quelque chose
pour toi ça a été au contraire une
expérience assez déconcertante de
recevoir cette victoire j'étais intimité
à cette époque et j'avais peur de pas
être à la hauteur du dax est sans fond
elle était plus grande que toi cette
chanson est plus grande que moi elle
puisse réussi que moi je dirais là un
début elle a une fin mais je comprends
comment elle est foutue moi j'ai
toujours pas compris
comment je suis fait et comment je
fonctionne je plaisante un petit peu
mais
je suis extrêmement fier de la
de l'incarner delà de la représenter
cheveux fier d'avoir finalement de
l'avoir fait et mais comme elle est 1 ça
je crois ça tu vois que un interprète je
suis pas du tout pour ne rien dire parce
que je suis qu'une petite partie de
cette ce succès mais c'est une petite
partie qui pondent c'est mon grain de
sel et je sais que dans ce grain de sel
j'ai réussi à être à faire croire à
cette histoire la thématique de cette
émission tu sais faire résistance c'est
le thème qu'on vous imposez à toi et à
ours et puis à romain notre photographe
qui en train d'oeuvrer juste à côté
qu'est-ce que ça t'inspire toi les
artistes en résistance aujourd'hui en
2021 ça veut dire quoi la résistance
c'est l'histoire de sa vie en fait de
supporter d'être qu'un artiste et de
faire des choses impalpable mais de
toute façon c'est pas pire entente peut
vite être un artiste que c'est pénible
mais c'est pénible toute la vie d'être
en ce1 de mode être enceinte de mélodies
d'être est de
30 artistes qui n'a pas la chance de
trouver un producteur ou un tourneur
se veut pas dire qu'il est naze
il va se débrouiller pour exprimer sa sa
créativité
à sa manière ça s'appelle
être au monde
c'est chaque sa manière d'être au monde
merci à vous merci beaucoup je sais
lequel plaisir on a conçu je connais du
bonheur un autre pc j'aime l'odeur des
draps après